Speaker 1: All right, let's get to Friday.
Feedback Friday. I like to take a look at what
folks have been saying. You know, we get five
or 6000 different comments a day across email,
YouTube, TikTok, etc.. It's impossible to look
at all of them, but I like to take a look at
a sampling and see some of the criticisms that
people are making, some of the praise and some
of the questions that people are asking. So let's
start first and foremost, let's just get this out
of the way, okay? 392 Choppa on YouTube says,
Who is paying you? This is a question rarely
asked in good faith. It usually implies that some
nefarious forces are funding this program or that
I only am saying the things I'm saying because
someone is giving me money or whatever the case
may be. So let me clarify. We fund this program
through three general categories. Number one,
memberships, people who just sign up on the
website. So like 392 Choppa could just as
easily be one of the people paying me as anybody
else. That's one of our funding sources. Secondly,
the platform for some of the platforms we're on
provide ad revenue for the little ads that show up
like before a video or in between videos, and that
includes YouTube, that includes Facebook, that
includes more recently Tik Tok, not Instagram. So
that's another funding source. And then lastly,
direct ad sales that we do. So like when you
hear me talking about a product or service,
the that's who pays me. There is no big
millionaire or billionaire donor. There is no
DNC money. I'm not even a Democrat. I don't know
why the DNC would pay me or I tell you of things
that I like about Democrats and things I don't.
Not clear why there would be an incentive there.
And that's basically the bottom line. That's it.
There's nothing sketchy or secret going on. And
one of the great things about that way of being
funded is there is no one person that can even
attempt to hold the money over our heads to get
me to say or not say whatever. There's no single
advertiser that's so big that they could come and
say, Hey, we really don't like what you're saying
about X or Y or whatever. They would say, Listen,
we have many advertisers and we aside from the
fact that I would never do that even financially,
like you don't really have me over a barrel. Same
thing with our audience members. One person who's
a member says, David, I will pull my $3 a month.
If you don't take back that thing you said
there's just no leverage. Okay? There's no
leverage. So that's who is paying me.
And by the way, organizations like The
Daily Wire and others actually do have the big
donors, organizations like Turning Point USA,
have the big donors focus on them. There's
no exciting story about who's paying us.
Scottie wrote in and Scottie says, I know you
won't, but I feel a ton of us want you to run
for president. Well, Scottie, I legally cannot run
for president of the United States. I was not born
in the United States. I was born in Argentina. And
at least for now. Maybe Arnold Schwarzenegger will
get the law changed at some point. I'm not sure. I
would not legally be allowed to run for president.
So I hate to if if it is true that there are a
ton of us that want me to run for president, as
Scottie says. I hate to disappoint, but it's just
not going to be possible under current law. John
Toole says I wouldn't vote for Chris Christie,
but it is nice to hear a Republican sound more
like they used to again. It's just nice to see
a Republican talking on an adult level again.
As of now, Christie really does have the strongest
campaign start on the Republican side. Hands down,
agree completely. It's not even close. It's not
even close. Vivek Ramaswamy is campaign is just
a mess. It's like a verbal, verbal inkblot. Nikki
Haley's campaign is a joke. Tim Scott's campaign
is laughable. Mike Pence is couldn't possibly have
less energy. Okay, you go through all of them,
then you get to Ron DeSantis. He's just a complete
and total disaster in terms of his campaign focus
on Anti-woke, his inability to in any remotely
charismatic way actually go against the guy who's
leading, which is Trump. Then we get Trump. Okay,
you got Trump. It's Christie. It's and I am not
voting for Christie. I'm not a Republican. It's
just if I had to vote for a Republican, it's so
obviously Chris Christie. And Jon is finding that
he's coming away with the same perspective. Bruton
Road on Reddit says There is a growing number
of people in my community and others believing
conservative propaganda that Democrats
are the party of slavery and it's working.
Why aren't we trying to stop this? Yes, I know
Democrats in the 1800s did form the Confederacy,
but we also know pushing the narrative in 2023
that Democrats are the true racist party without
full and proper context is clearly agenda based
and not a good faith discussion. My question is,
why isn't more being done to combat this? I'm
guessing most people are not seeing how big of
a problem this is becoming in the black community.
Well, listen, a couple of things. First of all, I
don't know that it's becoming a big problem in the
black community, because if black folks were being
tricked into thinking that the modern Democratic
Party is the party of slavery, you wouldn't
see such high levels of support for Democratic
candidates from the black community. Black folks
and Jewish folks are the two groups that most vote
Democratic in the United States. And my belief is
that if either of those groups were falling for
the lie that the Democrats of the Confederacy
are the Democrats of 2023, you wouldn't see
those levels of support. That being said, yes,
I do think it would be better to more strongly
disabuse people of the notion that there is a
connection between Democrats of the Civil War era
and Democrats of 2023 in order to explain this.
You do have to go into some history about party
realignments and different things. I think that
it's worth doing. Part of it would be great to
do in school at the educational level and prevent
people from ever falling for this stuff in the
first place. But the one part I take issue with
this viewer is that I'm not seeing the evidence
that it is really convincing to many people.
Doesn't mean we don't want to combat it, but it
doesn't seem like as big an issue as this person
is worried about. Chris or T's comments. Why don't
what what you don't get, bud, is the reason the
economy is so strong is because of what Trump
did in his first term. And I guess you forget
how high inflation really is. I love guys like
you. You point out every bad point of a person
but offer no new insight. I bet you call yourself
an independent. Typical, but I may be wrong. Well,
listen, I am not a Democrat or a Republican, and
that says I'm independent, but I don't pretend
to be a centrist or anything like that. I'm on
the left. But when it comes to economic matters,
I try to remove politics as much as possible and
just give you the analysis based on the data,
the empirical analysis. There is no evidence I
can find that the current economic indicators
are what they are because of what Donald
Trump did in his first term. However, Chris,
I also don't go around putting the credit for the
economy being what it is squarely on the shoulders
of Joe Biden. Presidents in general make tweaks
that can affect the general direction of the
economy. But much of what is going on is bigger
than the United States, and it's certainly bigger
than what's in the Oval Office. The point I make
about the Biden economy is that there is a group
that says Biden doesn't deserve a second term
because the economy is so terrible and there is
no empirical data based case that you can make
that proves the economy is terrible. That's my
point. Vinnie wrote in and says, I find it crazy
that DeSantis is now running on, quote, destroying
the left and the media acts like this is normal
politics and not fascism. Imagine if a Democrat
ran on getting rid of all conservatism. That would
be on 24 seven Lupe on Fox and any other right
wing outlet. This guy is full on anti-democracy
and nobody seems to care 100%. Listen,
that applies to so many stories. Imagine if Barack
Obama was indicted on 37 counts and it turned out
that he obstructed an attempt to return classified
documents to their rightful custodians, that a
server room was flooded by draining the pool
at his resort, that he had boxes of classified
documents stacked up around his toilet. Just
imagine how the coverage would be different from
the right. And similarly, Ron DeSantis said, if I.
I will destroy the leftism if I become president.
If Joe Biden said we will destroy conservatism,
they would be saying, this guy is an authoritarian
fascist. He's dangerous. All of the things that we
know, they try to say at any opportunity. Vinnie
is completely right. There is a stunning double
standard out there about this issue. Dennis says
about Ron DeSantis, he is stopping homosexuality
in school, not banning educational books. I don't
know if Dennis actually means this, but you
realize that if what Ron DeSantis is trying
to do is to stop homosexuality in schools, that
that's extraordinarily disturbing. What does it
mean to stop homosexuality? Dennis isn't saying
stopping discussion of homosexuality in school.
Dennis seems to be saying stopping homosexuality
in school. You're going to ban gay people. From
what? Going to school? Teaching. What are you
talking about, Dennis? This is someone who's
trying to defend DeSantis and actually makes it
look even worse. Lastly, on the trans and drag
issue, Richard Martin said, If you want to raise
your kid to be a freak show, moved to another
country. Don't put that stuff in the school system
and try to screw up other kids heads. If you want
your kid to be a freak show that you're a business
to take him down to a gay bar throwing in the
door. Let them have them and leave a note on his
back saying this week, drop off when you're done
with them. Have fun. Simple solves the problem.
That is one sentence. No punctuation and it is
not even worthy of a response other than to remind
you this. And this person also has a Jack Daniels
bottle as their profile picture. This is what we
are up against. And as I've said before, we're
not going to convince Richard Martin that is wrong
in any reasonable amount of time. And so what we
have to do instead is activate people who don't
plan to vote. That's the much more direct and
efficient path towards trying to win elections.
Really sad stuff going on in this country. We
have a tremendous bonus show for you today.
Just a reminder that we will be off on Monday,
the federal holiday, Juneteenth. I hope everybody
has a great Monday. Whether you're working or not,
we will be off and then we'll be back the rest of
the week. All right, everybody. Great bonus show
today. Sign up at Droid Pack Mint.com. You can use
the coupon code. Indicted and get indicted again.